Move over, Lady Gaga and J.Lo.
At Wednesday's star-studded inauguration, US Senator Bernie Sanders...
...somehow managed to steal the spotlight with his supersized mittens.
This photo of Sanders cutting a curmudgeonly figure in his grandpa chic mittens,...
...sent the internet into a meme frenzy.
Sanders has been spliced atop the throne from Game of Thrones,...
...seated next to Forrest Gump on that famous bench,...
...even placed high above New York City in the legendary photo...
..."Lunch Atop a Skyscraper."
Sanders told CBS News, his viral attire was merely a practical decision.
You know, in Vermont, we dress warm. We know something about the cold.
We're not so concerned about good fashion. We wanna keep warm.
And that's what I did today.
The mittens that stole the show were made by teacher Jen Ellis...
...from Sanders' home state of Vermont.
She gifted them to Sanders over two years ago.
But sorry, you can't get your hands on them anytime soon.
Because the pandemic has forced the cancellation of craft fairs,...
...Ellis hasn't been knitting mittens for sale lately.
Exclusivity.
How chic.